but I I need to call them to fix it but
I just like can't bring myself to do it
can't call people wait the AC is broken
but do they owe you to fix it it's not
even gonna cost you a thing it's the
landlord fixes it I know but the same
but I like this oh see I don't like to
suffer like that I'm not told pain slow
like you
[Music]
have you guys ever thought about moving
to an island in my dreams which island
you're talking about like a small one
you're like a small island yeah but I
feel like I'd get bored pretty easily
yeah do they have a Walmart or a Target
what about like an Irish Island oh
that's even worse I feel like um what
the [__] why I feel like Irish islands
are very like uh they don't get much
sunlight do they have a mark is that
wrong
you're talking about because of the
Irish skin you think that Irish people
don't get sunlight right well it's not
like in Ireland like uh you know it's
it's typically pretty overcast like most
of the time okay as you were saying but
isn't overcast don't you get more sun
from overcast Nick I mean the UV rays
still go through the clouds do they
though they do huh yeah yeah but why are
they so pale though because it's a
lighter one
you're in the northern hemisphere the
sun isn't as intense yeah that's that's
what I was that's what I meant thank you
for for taking my life
yeah exactly the equator's son is like
danger yeah yeah it'll [__] you up so um
in Ireland they have announced that they
will pay people up to 92 Grand to
refurbish a house I'm one of 30 Irish
Islands 30 of them Bart showed me this
one I was like how far does Hannah live
from here
90. the program is called our living
Islands it's a Visionary project from
the Irish government they want to
rejuvenate around 30 sparsely populated
offshore spots and of course there's
going to be a catch to this
um it's it's obviously aimed at
revitalizing areas
um but the aspiring dwellers are going
to need to purchase and own a property
provided it was constructed prior to
1993. it has remained vacant for at
least two years oh and the money you're
paid can only be used on building work
from structural improvements to
redecoration Steve in the article does
it say how long the flight time is from
LAX to Ireland does it say that in the
article it's 12 hours okay cool are you
sure can you just made that flight from
Dublin to L.A how long was it I slept I
forgot
no I went to Chicago
that's a big difference Joe
a huge difference
gigantic difference
so anybody can own uh anybody can buy
proper property in Ireland but it
doesn't guarantee you the right to live
there another caveat what yeah what do
they want then you might be able to get
a work visa you might you have to
um try to pursue dual citizenship this
is a stupid initiative Yeah the more you
read it just like everything right I I
can be a citizen it's like they want
this to happen but then you're making it
impossible for it to happen it's
probably for Irish citizens good job
first and foremost oh to just move like
a little ways down yeah because Bart
sent me this article we started looking
at all the places that they were
offering yeah and they're all on the
west coast of Ireland which no one
really lives on how come I mean this
Island's small right you could go across
it pretty quick but then most of the
people are on the East Coast because
that's the it's closer to like England
oh and then so everyone you know that's
why a lot of Irish people go to
Liverpool and all that stuff because
it's the closest and there's a ferry
that takes a couple of hours to go back
and forth but all the islands it's like
even if you fly to Dublin or whatever it
takes several hours in like shitty roads
to get there well people also and you
had to take a boat people also assume
that like you're gonna have like a
Walmart on the island right but
infrastructure there is non-existent nah
you gotta [__] sheep dude that's all
you got remember when Mr Beast gave that
kid an island who like the kid won an
island and then he starved to death on
the [__] Island he thought there
would be a Target there Dad no he's dead
but he had nothing but a 7-Eleven
I think you would survive on 7-Eleven
but they won't trade you coconut that
always seems like that's the trade-off
is whenever they do these initiatives
it's like oh here's all this money that
you have to put into the house but you
have to spend the money at a local
supplier yeah that's like Italy when
they're giving you those homes the same
thing yeah but you got to fix up those
homes there maybe where you buy stuff
isn't as easy to buy as Like Home Depot
or some [__] yeah I mean that's why no
one wants to live there dude there's
like whole ass ghost towns now in Japan
everyone's moving to the city if people
who are native to the area don't want to
move there yeah that's [__] it's over
way harder for guys like us they're
giving them the houses and money and
they're like nah and when we go over
there we're not gonna know what they're
saying like maybe 75 you will
yeah my whole thing is do I have to do a
good job
because if they give me like 90 grand
and they're like redecorate I'm like I
go to [__] Ikea yeah we meet you guys
don't have an Ikea what are what are the
terms of redecorating what if there's a
what if that's that's your worker on he
goes well I finished my decorating it's
just Bitcoin miners
how's it look it's actually a cooler
region too
I think we just created the evil idea
110 degrees in your house but when you
think of like dating an island I think
everyone's thinking of tropical not some
cold ass like Game of Thrones ass Island
yeah with a bunch of Seagulls just
sitting [__] all over the place like
the Iron Throne right yeah those [__]
guys the gray Joys you're like yeah
their Kingdom looks terrible that's like
Waikiki Beach dude like you're in the
water and your feet are getting all cut
up on the Rocks also the best part about
towns like that is the community that
exists there so if you're not part of
that they'll hate you probably won't
have a good time you think you can't get
some Irish people to like you though I
don't think so they're pretty friendly
I'm not though Brian's really
interesting
Outsider to them yeah I don't know what
they're saying but you know what how
would that feel if you had a a
tight-knit neighborhood and you knew
that some guy accepted 92 000 to live in
your [__] it probably wouldn't feel too
good right yeah you might just naturally
and you're going to the well [__]
don't got shoes I might be so bored of
the six other people that are there I'm
happy to like now like when am I ever
going to go to America so now there's
this person I get to meet an American
and it's whatever and it sucks because
he's Japanese-American
laughs
it's not even the real thing man it's a
Twist but we're gonna go see the
American guy like Joe mentioned in Italy
they did this but like they only gave
people like 33 Grand so for most people
like this is a huge boostie and consider
like the most generous of any country's
offering so far to come fix our shits
yeah that's a lot that means it's
probably for sure hard mode gotta be
yeah gotta be that's tough you're
probably like [__] taking a boat to
Lowe's dude
yeah it's DIY everything how many trips
everything's green there's no other
colors
dude imagine because dude for me and if
you were moving in I swear to God this
[__] is sending me to Lowe's like every
other minute
and I just get home and then she's like
oh I also need this and I'm like I was
just a [__] love yeah and they don't
have hardware stores out there what are
you gonna do Amazon imagine you forget a
hammer or something you gotta go all the
way back on the boat oh my God you're
gonna rub it too no motor Dude
You're Gonna Roll It Up a waterfall
damn oh I lost my tube I forget
yeah you work for it that is crazy I
watched with that one show where they
like live in Alaska that's all I was
just gonna say man they got a [__]
helicopter everything in or they have
one of those planes that land on water
and [__] [__] hits the fat yeah like
if one of the machines break like you're
just out on your own holy [__] during
snowstorms or whatever that's it they
just have to survive no one could get to
them I feel like that's what would
happen is you'd go and you'd be like oh
there's no AC who's the HVAC guy in the
village and they go we're hoping it
could be you yeah
what do you say huh
can you guys do it though like you think
you can be a homesteader hell no no I
can't even do it here no yeah yeah you
got all the resources here this is as
easy mode as it gets yeah dude I was
losing my mind the other day because
it's because it was hot in Vegas and
[__] and then like my I have like a
little fan next to me because I already
have air conditioning in my house but it
doesn't for some reason I'm [__]
cursed right no matter where me and
Nikki's last condo the air conditioner
doesn't reach my office and in this
house the air conditioner doesn't reach
my office so I have to use fans and [__]
is it hot as hell in here it's
absolutely Sports and hot it's Las Vegas
Nevada dude so you start sweating is it
isn't going to
so then I have like a little I have like
a little fan that I got on Amazon and I
have to like keep filling it up with
water oh so yeah oh it really like
[__] sweating and [__] yeah I bet
that feels nice though when it hits it
feels good when it's filled up with
water
do you feel like you're in line at Six
Flags
[__] bro I do dude Steve has the spray
bottles with a fan on it and then I go
like he's like yeah honey can you like
come give me give me a [__] whatever
the [__] and I go I bring it upstairs
I'm like oh it's so nice out here are
you considering moving your office I'm
thinking considering it I think you
might have to I might have to just use
my laptop more still doesn't get AC in
here every time he keeps moving though
it gets cut off yeah it gets cut off in
the window but that's why it's so
[__] hot you don't want to just get
another unit for like a window unit
no because I'm I'm too cheap
yeah I don't want to do that I was
looking like this little thing I have
that's all I got
it's like 60 bucks on Amazon dude do you
kind of like the suffering though I do
I know what you mean I kind of like that
my office is the hottest room in the
[__] house
yeah dude because like my office is like
an add-on bro it's like if I and I've
talked about it on here before but if I
push hard enough on the ceiling my hands
will go right through the [__] wall
like way more than this dude like it's
it's made out of [__] nothing it's
paper mache oh geez and it gets so
[__] hot and the AC is broken but I I
need to call them to fix it but I just
like can't bring myself to do it can't
call people wait the AC is broken do
they owe you to fix it huh it's not even
a costume a thing it's the landlord
fixes it I know but at the same but I
like this it really won't cost anything
oh see I don't like to suffer like that
I'm not told pain slow like you when
you're a renter you're supposed to call
your land
well actually only once pressing matters
you're like hey I'm out of toilet paper
he's like I don't do that [__] bro what
the [__] are you talking about can you
just bring me something he goes all
right
so I did the stove thing again
I just needed to tell someone
did he hear about that does your
landlord know about Jake what was his
fault because he installed that huh it's
his stove that he put in there right
yeah I think this they gave us a [__]
ass stove I think right yeah that's the
narrative we all went with [__] asked of
I didn't touch it at all that's what I
said he didn't do it I woke up your dog
that you don't have at the time climbed
up and hit it where's the fanny pack
right now where is it on your steep suit
it doesn't fit my steep suit so I took
it off yeah I feel kind of naked though
[Music]